Hello and welcome to this video on Example 5, an FBX import pipeline tool.
For this, we're jumping back into the editor.
And for this, we're going to be on slide 11, Example 5, batch FBX importer.
Now, this is where we are going to create a tool that you might use in order to control your pipeline,
an importing pipeline.
Now, if we were to jump back into the file structure,
we'd see next to the Python code, we have a directory that's called FBX import directory.
And what this tool is going to do is it's going to take any of the FBXs
and import them into like a staging directory.
And then we're going to be able to correct the naming convention.
And then we're going to be able to sort them to their appropriate folders,
all with a couple of clicks of the button.
OK, so these are our meshes that we're going to work with.
Now, for this, we're using a editor utility widget.
So if I was to double click on this here,
now we would open up what our editor utility widget looks like.
Hopefully, you should have some experience with putting together editor utility widgets at this point.
It's much similar to how you would put together something in the game engine
if you're working with Unreal Motion Graphics.
But it's our tool for making menus and systems.
So in this, I've just got a few different buttons and a few different panels.
I've got a directory to import to, a couple of buttons for each of the tasks.
And a output window for our error message.
And if I was to jump into the graph here,
you can see I'm making quite a lot of use of the Python,
execute Python scripts here.
So you can see in this, I'm getting the directory text,
using it as the directory text
and the output I'm using as the message so that I can update our output in.
And for each one of the buttons, we have a different Python script.
And yeah, for each one of the buttons, we have a different Python script here.
OK, so for editor utility widgets,
now the teaching aid is a good example of an editor utility widget
and one that is fired up on startup.
So you could do a similar thing with this,
or you could start it up off of a menu or something else.
Now, if I right-hand click,
you'll see there is an option to run editor utility widgets.
That's going to open this up here.
So I now have my script
and I'm going to jump to the imported directory.
Now, see this going, so this is the directory
that I want to import stuff to.
If I push the import FBX button,
you can see that it's going to come in,
it's going to import these one by one.
Now you can see we had all of our different meshes.
One of them has a specific material texture,
which is packaged with the FBX.
You can see it here with this crisscross button.
And so we have this all in our imported.
Now, if I was to hit the fix prefixes,
you can see it's going to take everything
that's in that directory.
And very similar to our prefix,
it's going to add the appropriate prefixes to it.
So the prefix is 11 of 12 assets.
And finally, I'm going to push the sort to directory
and they're all gone.
But you can see within the meshes directory,
we have the meshes.
Within the material directory, we have the material
and the texture has been moved to the texture directory.
So what is nice about this and any sort of pipeline tool
is it will allow you to not only control the naming
from the prefixes and the location
based on sorting it to the directory,
but on the import script,
which we will have a quick look at,
you can actually control a whole load of settings
of how you want something imported.
So this is the import script here.
And this is the import script here.
You can see that we are able to build an import task
and set the editor properties for each of these.
And we can set, for example, the import textures are true,
import materials are true.
And there are lots of other just settings
you can find within the API.
But it's an example of how we can control this.
And again, it is worth looking through
any of these examples
in case it's doing something similar
to what you're looking to achieve.
They should sort of help you out.
And that brings us to the end of the example
for the FBX import pipeline tool.
Thank you very much.